so I guess just to start off with you
know like Dumbo what is the worst
nickname you've ever been given me yes
oh my god I've got I mean I think of my
father bears worse than my father calls
me
Vava voom it's like you know when your
car and you're going bah bah boom it
seems like a compliment it's a
compliment no one no one would insult
you so this is like your third
collaboration with Tim so I'm interested
do you see any sort of similarities
between the roles he cast you in
I mean it's Tim Burton so you know he's
the master are dealing at like outsiders
and so I've played here in doc shadows
she was kind of like a misunderstood
which rejected misunderstood been in
miss Peregrine's she was a woman bird
kind of an outcast and then here
Colette's got it is less is less I don't
see less CooCoo she's kind of a more
kind of clear character but an aerialist
so you know there and it's the circus so
it's very colorful and bigger-than-life
what is it about yourself that makes you
a perfect fit for sort of Burton's
you know world I don't know people say
I'm strange but I've embraced my
strangeness of Gothic miss I won't ever
say do you have it sort of the look of
collide how old like do you do you get
to decide what she wears and yeah I mean
that's the wonderful thing you know I
mean Tim Burton is Tim Burton and he is
very open and Colleen Atwood who is a
genius designer is also very open they
don't impose like this is what you're
going to wear they really want you to
feel comfortable because they want you
to be able to perform and you know to
feel confident and and yeah we I mean of
course Colleen had amazing ideas but she
listens to you she you know
it did the look of Colette is so kind of
movie star theatrical you know it's like
big that's a feathers it's colorful
vibrant and there's amazing like
performance outfits you know like it's
just you feel like you were princess how
many different designs did they show you
oh I don't know I decide she goes slowly
she was like I remember they're the
first two to dress that I wear was pink
and I was like really pink and she was
like okay let's go for red you know but
I can't remember but she's very open
it's like you know we work slowly and we
kind of build it together do you ever
get to take any of these outfits home or
I mean you've been on these sets do you
ever want to take anything from me set
sir they're so beautiful
totally it is it is amazing becoming to
set some real yeah I always see like a
lamp I'm like ooh I like that lamp look
go to my living room when you're when
you're flying a trapeze artists how much
research sort of goes into their
movements and sort of body like I mean
it's it's very its concrete I had to
train with like real circus people so
that was I was amazing because you you
get to train for free with the most
amazing circus performers and and I was
so scared of heights it was real phobia
mm-hmm and I really panicked at the
beginning but you know I really uh you
know I got over it I mean it's amazing
it's it's I can't believe I can swing I
I thought I would die if I was going to
go up there but what are the tips to get
over sort of a fear of heights you need
to you need very good you know trainers
and you need to sing and when you go up
there you need to scream and sing yeah
and then it all we're always fine are
those legitimate exercises to just sing
sing is my own thing is
this is it was my my secret tip know
what sort of exercises do they do for
sort of I mean first of all you need to
strengthen your core a lot in your arms
it's such a difficult craft it's amazing
and and then you know off you go you
have to do weird things up there
you